c'est tous les jours la même chose
personne n'est prêt
tu as beau faire comme ça
il y a du boulot de sur moi donc c'est
normal
après le 49-3 les réquisitions sont vus
comme une violence supplémentaire de la
part de l'exécutif le gouvernement avec
les conneries qui fait depuis des
semaines maintenant il rajoute par
dessus la casse du droit de grève dans
le pays mais jamais dans la vie ça va
passer ça jamais dans la vie elle se
laisser refaire il va nous rester quoi
on va devoir travailler des années de
plus pour continuer à les gaver on
devrait accepter ça et en plus à coup de
tricks mais jamais il rêve
avant d'arriver j'ai lu un article sur
vous dans lequel vous disiez on me vend
comme un gros bourrin il y a du vrai là
dedans il y a un côté bourrin chez vous
ah non moi je me trouve magnifique
oui la valeur des artisans qui font
grève par procuration
moi j'étais sur un chantier hier avec
des arcs problèmes premiers monsieur
Marty c'est de recruter du personnel et
ça c'est pas la faute à Monsieur Macron
c'est la faute qu'on a qu'on est en
train de gendrer une population une
génération de branleurs et qui veulent
pas travailler voilà la la problématique
de la France nous allons leur imposer
une défaite comme ils n'ont jamais connu
on est à deux doigts de la victoire
Olivier Mathieu conclu par sa formule
est-ce qu'on va manquer des sens
marine Sabourin en Ille-et-Vilaine
regardez ce reportage
nous le montrons pas mais
[Musique]
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais on le dit
pas bon elle a pompé sans se faire rare
près de la moitié des stations sont à
sec dans les Bouches-du-Rhône plus d'une
sur deux étant manque d'au moins un type
de carburant une situation quasi
identique dans le Gard et le Vaucluse
des pénuries qui touchent également
quelques départements de l'Ouest comme
la Loire-Atlantique ou l'Ille-et-Vilaine
certains forcément sont tentés d'aller
un peu plus loin de prendre un peu plus
que 30 litres le remplissage des
jerricanés est également interdit et
juste derrière moi un monsieur est en
train de remplir un joli cadre on va lui
poser une question
[Musique]
quand même cet après-midi plusieurs
centaines d'étudiants ont défilé à Paris
pour demander le retrait de la réforme
des retraites
une ambiance bonne enfant et des jeunes
très engagés il faut quand même rappeler
qu'il n'y a eu aucun vote c'est que
passer par par la force et donc pour
nous c'est pas normal parce qu'en fait
ils ont marre j'en ai marre de devoir
galérer ils ont marre de voir leurs
parents galérer j'en ai marre de voir
leur grand-parents galéré et donc cette
réforme des retraites elles sonnent
comme le moment où il faut se mobiliser
Y ou Z elles sont parfois désenchantées
en pensant à leur avenir
merci Nadia cette réforme elle est
débile parce qu'elle n'a pas revu le
financement je te ça fait des ça fait ça
fait des mois
il faut taxer le produit fini il faut
taxer la machine comme l'homme quand la
machine a remplacé l'homme quand tu as
une machine qui remplacée sans dôme mais
il faut que la machine soit placé
pour les artichauts on leur coupe la
queue on leur arrache les poils et on
leur bouffe le cul c'est
allez allez allez
les Français ne seront restés qu'un an
dans le club des 20 peuples les plus
heureux classement soutenus par les
Nations Unies après s'être hissé à la
vingtième place dans l'édition
précédente son meilleur score depuis la
création de l'enquête la population
française passe cette année en 21e
position lorsqu'un score très sérieux
j'ai dit c'est sous l'égide des Nations
Unies et alors les critères qui ont été
pris en compte en fait pour calculer le
niveau de bonheur des différents pays
sont écoutez bien le PIB le niveau de
solidarité le niveau de corruption
l'état des libertés individuelles et
bien sûr l'absence ou non Dani dalgo et
si on dégringole autant c'est qu'un pays
qui gagne 14 places dans ce classement
la Lituanie figure-toi mais qui est
premier
[Musique]
4 poulets rôti évidemment la petite
sauce
[Musique]
parce qu'il y a un taux d'alcoolémie
alors tu sais quand tu es obligé de
ton filer une bouteille de vodka parce
que
boivent et ils se sont obligés
résumons-nous Emmanuel Macron est
évidemment le premier responsable du
chaos qui arrive mais il n'existe pas de
majorité alternative Marine Le Pen tient
plutôt bien son rôle depuis des mois
mais personne n'imagine un consensus
autour de sa personne les républicains
et la gauche républicaine n'existent pas
ou n'existe plus la France insoumise
donne une image de la politique
effrayante l'extrême gauche a théorisé
la violence cette année on monte une
pièce qui était écrite par un des
comédiens mais c'est super agréable la
pièce il s'appelle quel bordel les
écologistes sont largués la Cinquième
République la Constitution
institutions sont en danger les patrons
passent pour des braqueurs de pauvres
nous avons 3000 milliards de dettes il
n'y a plus un sous dans les caisses
regardez ça se passait au Mexique pour
célébrer l'arrivée du Platon du
printemps alors depuis les airs en
montgolfière ou au pied des pyramides ou
théotiques alors il lève les bras et
vous allez voir il faut un autre signe
ça c'est pour capter l'énergie du soleil
voilà donc ça fait beaucoup de bien ça
porte de l'énergie positive l'école et
défaillante la justice fait débat
l'administration est obèse le nucléaire
est abîmé la sécurité dans la rue est un
problème l'immigration et hors contrôle
les prix augmentent etc etc bref et
pardonnez-moi de le dire comme ça ce
matin d'une manière aussi triviale
nous sommes dans la merde
on va s'épilarder avec vous puis vous
allez chanter aussi pour nous
ça c'est pas du tout